그래서 여러분들이
리모델링을 한다라는 생각을 하셨으면
여기까지
분석을 해야 돼요 여기까지
[음악]
비 사람입니다 제가 오늘은
리모델링 할 만한 건물을
검토하기 전에 어떤 것들을 봐야 될지
좀 영상을 찍어 보도록 하겠습니다이
건물이 그 리모델링 하기 너무 좋은
건물이더라고요 일단은 토지이용계획을
볼 거예요 요거는 이제 3종으로 돼
있고 3종이였죠 건폐율 50%의
용증이 250% 이제 건축물대장을
가야 되는데 건축물대장은 제가 출력을
했습니다 봐야 될게 건폐율이
50%라고 그랬잖아요 근데 이거는
59%를 받았습니다 그래서 한 9%
정도 이득을 봤어요 그래서 이런
건물들이 여러분들이 찾다보면 있거든요
예전에는
종이 세분화가 안 돼 있었습니다
그래서
2003년도 전해지은 건물들 보면은
종이 1종 2종 3종이 세분화가 안
돼 있어서 이렇게 좀
초과돼서
지은 건물들이 있어요
초과된 건 아니죠 그때 당시에
적법하게 허가 받았으니까 이거는
건폐율 59%고
용적률이 무려
272%입니다 지금 법정은
250%인데
22% 정도 더 받았어요 그래서
이거는 멸시라면
면적이 더 줄어들어요 줄어들어서 지울
수밖에 없거든요
요게 딱 리모델링 하기 딱 좋은
건물입니다
일단은 대지면적이 275.4 한
83평 정도
83평인데 아까 용적률 몇 프로 이름
봤죠 22% 정도
면적으로 치자면 한 18평 정도 더
이득을 본 겁니다 그래서
총 연면적이
한
266평 정도 됩니다
근데 저는 제일 중요한게 예상
임대료를
판단하는게 제일 중요하다고 보거든요
임대를 얼마에 맞출 수 있는지가 되게
중요합니다 좀 보기 편한게 이제
네이버 부동산 여기 월세에서 보면요
주변에 나와 있는 사례들이 되게
많아요
요거를 보고 대략 판단할 수가 있죠
215평인데
3,700에 나와 있습니다 한
17만원 정도 되거든요 평당 근데
정확하게 여러분들 임대료 계산하려면
전용면적으로
계산을 하긴 해야 돼요 일단
대략적으로 보면
이것도 한 17만원 요것도 만약에 잘
맞추면
18만원 18만원 정도는 충분히 맞출
것 같아요 그러면 한
4,800 정도 되거든요
월세가 여러분들이 이렇게 좀 그 주변
임대 시세를 토대로 이렇게 예상
임대를 좀 계산을 해 봐야 됩니다
월세가 한 요정도 나올 것 같아요 한
4천만원 후반 정도 그리고 또
여러분들이 건축물대장에서 보셔야 될게
이게 일단 구조를 좀 봐야 돼요
구조가 지금 철근 콘크리트로 돼 있죠
근데 만약에 이제
연화조로 되어 있거나 할 경우에는
비용이 조금 더 들 수도 있습니다
아니면 건물을 좀 더 올린다고 했을
때 보강을 해야 될 수도 있어요
연화조로 되어 있기 때문에 근데 이거
같은 경우엔 철근 콘크리트로 다 돼
있고 여러분들이 또 보셔야 될게
용도에요 용도
건축물대장상의 좀 이렇게
용도가
실제 사용하는 용도랑 다른 경우도
있거든요
확인을 하셔야 됩니다 그리고 면적
면적도 확인해야 돼요 그래서 딱
리모델링 하기는 딱 좋은 건물이에요
위에까지 반듯하게 올라왔어요 요것도
북향이다 보니까 일조권 사선을 거의
안 받은 것 같습니다 여러분들이
가끔씩 보다 보면 보통은 일조권 사선
받으면 한 3층부터 일조권 사선을
받아요 면적이 줄어드는 경우가 많은데
실제로 가서 봤는데 이렇게
5층까지 반듯한 건물들이 많습니다
불법으로 사용하고 있는 경우도
많거든요
면적이 이렇게 보통 한 4 5층부터
줄어드는데
그렇게 줄어든
부분이 있는지 그런 것도 좀 봐야
되고 그리고 또 봐야 될게 주차대수
여기 보면 자주식
총 7대 그래서 실제로 가서 7대가
맞는지 봐야 되고
도면을
볼 수 있으면 좋아요 그래서 도면을
봤는데
7대가 이렇게 잘 돼 있는지 그
부분도 판단을 해야 되고 그리고
요거는 사용 승인 일이 97년도 그
엘레베이터가
요거는 설치가 되어 있어요
요거를 이제 뭐 그대로 사용할지
아니면 바꿀 건지 뭐 이런 것도 봐야
되고 여러분들이 또 봐야 되는 것
중에 하나가
변동 사항 부분을 봐야 돼요 변동사항
전에 한번
많은 건축물이 한번 적발된 적이 있죠
요게 어떤 부분이
적발이 됐는지 이런 내역들이 남습니다
물론 지금 풀려 있긴 하지만 조정한게
맞는지
여러분들이이 건축물대장을 보면 판단할
수 있어요
변동 사항까지도 보셔야 됩니다 그래서
지금이 건물 같은 경우엔 건물을 못
부실 이유가 없어요 이미 오버돼서
받았기 때문에이 모델링 하기 너무
좋은 건물이고 보니까 이거를 135억
정도에 샀더라구요 만약에 취득세 중과
이슈가 없다라고 하면은
취득세 중간은 이제 뭐 신규 법인이
뭐 본점이 과밀억제권형 내에 있는데
매입을 했다거나 이런 경우에
9.4%거든요 일반적으로
4.6% 받았다고 하면
취득세가 한 6억 2천 정도 됩니다
기타 비용까지 한 6억 5천 정도
매입하는데는 한 130 1억 5천
정도요 정도 들었을 것 같고
리모델링 비용이 뭐 대략 이게 뭐
자재를 어떤 거 쓰느냐 어떻게
하느냐에 따라 다르지만 대략 한
20억 정도 들었다고 치면 한
160억 정도
될 것으로 예상이 되면 월세가이 정도
나오고 아까 10만원 후반 정도
그리고 뭐 160억 정도 들었다고
치면은
수익률이 한요 정도 되죠 이거를 제가
160억 정도 투자했는데 거의 한
200억 정도는 봐야 되잖아요 나중에
지금 보증금이 한 5억 정도 빠지겠죠
그러면 대략 요정도 됩니다 3% 정도
월세가 18만원 정도 받는데 그 정도
했을 때 한 4,800 정도 나온다는
가정하에는 나중에 매각 가격 예상했을
때 한 200억 정도는
그래도
매각이 될 것 같아요 그래서 오늘 좀
정리를 해보자면 제가 일단 건물 볼
때 토지이용계획 첫 번째 받고 3종인
거 확인했고 그 다음에 건축물대장까지
떼서 봤습니다 그래서 건축물대장을
떼서 건폐율 용적률을 확인했고이 사례
같은 경우에는 건폐율이나 용적률이
이득권 건물이었고 용도란 구조를 좀
봤었고 그 다음에 면적 그 다음에
주차대수
엘리베이터가 있는지 없는지 그리고
마지막으로
변동 사항까지 확인을 했습니다
기존에 뭐 위반건축물이 적발됐던 내역
그런 것
확인을 했고 지금은 해제가 잘 되어
있는지 안 돼 있는지까지 확인을 해야
됩니다 그 다음에 주변에 임대
시세까지 파악을 해서 어느 정도
임대료를 마쳤을 때 어느 정도
매각이 가능한지까지 제가
파악을 했습니다 그래서 여러분들이
리모델링을 한다라는 생각을 하셨으면
여기까지
분석을 해야 돼요 여기까지 그리고
제일 중요한 건 제가 지금 그냥
컴퓨터 상으로만 보기는 했지만
현장 가서 봐야 된다 불법 1번
건축물이 있는지 없는지 건물이 어떻게
돼 있는지 엘레베이터 아까 봤지만
있긴 하지만 너무 오래된 것도 바꿔야
되거든요 그거는
현장을 가야지만 볼 수가 있습니다
정확한
판단은 현장을 가서
꼭 눈으로 확인하고
판단을 하셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고
현장 갈 때 제일 좋은 건축사님이랑
손잡고 가서 보시면 됩니다 이거
리모델링 했을 때
요렇게 가능한지 공사비가 대략적으로
제가 어떤 자제를 쓰는데 어느 정도
들지를 건축사님의 의견을 충분히
듣고
판단을 하셨으면 좋겠습니다 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 여러분들 리모델링
투자하실 때 알아야 될 항목들을 좀
이렇게 정리해서 말씀을 좀 드렸습니다
투자하는데 도움이 되셨으면 좋겠고
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하도록
하겠습니다
감사합니다